i just want to share with you a couple
of minutes and you interject go ahead
right so clayton gets appointed
immediately he is called clayton this
former sec chair former thank you former
sec chair jay clayton immediately he's
described by rolling stone magazine as
the most conflicted sec chairman in the
history of the united states because of
his connection to the banks and the wall
street
in his confirmation hearing him and
elizabeth warren go back he agrees that
he should recuse himself that he should
never
vote
against one of his clients having an
enforcement action like he has to step
back right so that goes on he gets his
good friend
william hinman to become the director of
corporation and finance these guys are
heavily connected they were the the main
sponsors of alibaba ipo and many other
types of ipos bill hinman comes in jay
clayton is from firm sullivan and
cromwell okay and bill hinman is from
simpson thatcher well
immediately in december of 2017
sullivan and cromwell represents the
co-founder of ethereum joe lubin and
consensus and bill hinman has a meeting
with him and they start talking
immediately the very next day uh
consensus general counsel gets up and
starts talking about how they're
building this alliance with the sec
they go on to have four to five more
meetings with consensus and the
co-founders of ether with bill hinman
bill hinman's firm
so just so i get on track so you have a
private law firm the ethereum and then
you have the sec all together in in
meetings right what you have is you have
the co-founder of ethereum joe lubin and
the founder of consensus meeting with
sec
bill hinman and his firm is a member of
the enterprise ethereum alliance to what
end what what in what capacity what was
the
what was the reasoning for the meeting i
think he's getting to it
the reason for the media is because they
start lobbying for a ethereum free pass
right they want to say hey ethereum yeah
we maybe did an ico because it was the
world's first ico but it's to
sufficiently decentralize so jay clayton
then
tells andreessen horowitz which is a
huge investor in crypto right they have
the 2.2 billion fund big ether backers
he says write a memo up for us and tell
us what you want they write a memo and a
safe harbor proposal there are multiple
meetings that take place a secret
meeting in march
of 28th of 2018
and it gets leaked because there's some
stuff going on in there and they propose
a safe harbor for crypto but the only
crypto they mention is ether and then
what happens on june 14th
bill hinman gratuitously as director of
corporation and finance
very high up at the sec gives his
infamous speech where he says setting
aside the fundraising that took place
with ether
it is sufficiently decentralized today
and therefore current cells of ethereum
are no longer considered a security
he goes on cnbc
and he says well you know when we look
at ethereum we don't see a third party
promoter
you just had a meeting with him it's a
backroom deal you just had meetings with
him he had a meeting on june 8th six
days before the speech he had a meeting
with the promoter so he gets up there
and says we don't see it criminal law
this sounds like a proper meeting almost
and then absolutely then all the people
start asking what about xrp xrp was
actually number two at the time behind
bitcoin and it was battling ether for
the number two spot oh we're not going
to comment on any further tokens
joe lubin then goes out and starts
basically saying what the sec is going
to do he says we're working with the sec
they gave ether a pass they gave bitcoin
a pass all these other coins he
literally says this are
are
absolute spectacularly disadvantaged
compared to ether they didn't mention
xrp that's very interesting he says the
sec is going to be coming after certain
projects all of this takes place right
in the meantime
bill hinman is collecting 15 million
dollars from his law firm while he's at
the sec
which is a member of the enterprise
ethereum alliance right sullivan and
comrel which represents jay clayton's
firm that's his firm
they represent consensus
and the co-founder of ethereum wow right
all of that's going down now listen to
this
just before the lawsuit happens now in
the meantime in the meantime ripple's
allowed to buy nine percent of moneygram
and use xrp it's actually they're giving
it to moneygram who's then selling it on
exchanges for dollars
they a lot they coinbase in january 2019
goes to
the sec and says look our securities
lawyers
have decided that xrp is not a security
we want to list it what do you say sec
sec doesn't say anything
one month later xrp is listed on
coinbase
then in october
one river
comes out and they make a 1 billion bet
on bitcoin and ethereum that's in
october
and also
consensus decides that they're going to
buy quorum which is
a competitor to ripple they're trying to
replace swift the messaging and money uh
banking system basically which is what
ripple was in completely focused on
and then on the last day
you've got on a three to two vote who
does clayton go with he goes with the
two democrats even though he's a
republican votes to file the suit
against ripple as he's walking out the
door
his excuse has been reported well he
deferred to the staff
the director of enforcement leaves three
weeks later
to go to simpson and thatcher
clayton left
bill hinman left all of these senior
people
who were supposed to foresee this case
right and see it through all leave
two weeks before
what i mentioned earlier before this
happens joseph grundfest former sec
commissioner who helped ethereum
writes and i got the letter here writes
to clayton and the commissioners and
says listen
you've never made a material distinction
between ether and xrp
if xrp is a security ethers of security
if you're going to allow xrp ether to be
traded you've got to let
them trade he even goes as far as 15
million reasons why that's not true he
goes as far as to say if you file this
lawsuit
it calls into question the commission's
discretion this is like a damn john
grisham right man he says that and so
what happens
jay clayton votes for the lawsuit
the two democrats vote for it
the lawsuit's filed they all leave jay
clayton goes to one river
bitcoin and ether
and guess what
the people that helped write the hinman
speech and by the way these are all
facts on crypto law we have a video
library of all these interviews
dangerously close to making an
allegation here all right and and i will
tell you they basically um
uh come out and and bill hinman now
works
he's a partner
with the ether investors who helped
write the speech that gave ether a free
pass and that's not an allegation that's
facts because lawyers who are part of
the meeting have come out and said
i didn't think ether was sufficiently
decentralized but bill hinman did i'm
not sure why he did
15 million reasons might tell you why
being a partner at a 2.2 billion so
here's the thing about allegation i'm
not saying
that they broke a law but what i'm
saying tell me there's not enough for an
independent investigation
that's all we want we want an
independent investigation in the
meantime don't take john deaton's word
for it an independent organization in
power
is in litigation with the scc because
they won't turn over documents they
won't give us bill hinman's calendar how
is a guy who's being paid by tax dollars
director of corporation finance
they won't give us his calendars to who
he met when he met they won't release it
the this independent organization that
sued the sec asked for any ethics
discussions between bill between clayton
and the sec about his post-employment
hinman
they say there's no documents or they
won't give the documents the freedom of
information act they won't give it yeah
right this is
75 years 75 years now for the freedom of
information right so that's all in
litigation but that's what's going on
you know what i mean and so what i'm
doing is saying listen you want to go
after ripple after rip go after brad
garland house i don't care but
you are destroying people's lives
by attacking the token itself and why
did you allow the money grant to happen
why did you allow coinbase
to do it how how how does coinbase go in
there and say we're going to list xrp
unless you tell us otherwise
and then they don't and they list it and
then 18 months later as he's walking out
the door he slaps a lot told no yet
right but it's what i'm saying and so
let me ask you who hates if you were to
make a list of people who hate xrp who
would you say hate xrp not not dislike
who hated joe lubin who is the
co-founder of ethereum the founder of
consensus we have him on video saying
xrp is overvalued xrp is a coin uh
xrp this xrp is not a competitor and so
we're not worried about it the day of
the hinman's speech where he gave ether
the free pass
joe lubin goes on the same stage right
after bill hinman and he says these
words he says oh by the way i didn't get
to read all of the the speech
did they bring up xrp
and the moderator goes no he goes well
isn't that interesting
right
he goes on later in interviews to say
that the sec is going to be coming after
certain projects and any hints that it's
going to be
xrp
and and the thing that
that
you have to understand is the guy who's
saying xrp is not a competitor xrp is
not a competitor
why is it the first token you bring up
after you're given the free pass and the
other thing that the sec won't give us
is did you know that 63 emails went out
with that draft speech that gave ether a
free pass
do you know who was the only
commissioner to get a a draft version of
it was that jay clayton did you know
crypto mom herself hester purse never
saw it
how do you draft why would clayton even
be involved in that that draft like why
would he even
he gave input he's the only commissioner
bill hinman was deposed ripple was
successful in getting him deposed of
course they redact everything to the
public
and
i have it here if you want to see it
they at the lawyers ask them did you
ever uh represent how much is redacted
can i say
this is this goes to pat you were
telling a story a couple weeks back
about now this is you were at harvard
and you you said that there was a guy
who was having trouble he said just find
a congressman pay him a half a million
dollars he's going through an election
and he'll help you put up a lot to hurt
them this is it yeah
he's asked questions like have you ever
worked for ethereum foundation look at
the answers look at the freaking
look at the redactions all right and
this isn't the whole this is look at
this this isn't the whole
awesome dude are you kidding me
right this is insane now now
why would they redact pat
if he's asked a question
have you ever had clients that are part
of the ethereum foundation if i
represent you and your business yeah i
can't talk about what we talk about but
if some record
no it was an exhibit that's that's
probably right can we show this oh yeah
yes you can show it so like absolutely
so i don't know if people can see this
and this is ages of that this is an
entire page of every single word on the
page redacted and there's
there's
there's pages of it
this is your this is your transparent
security exchange commission holy moly
you were going somewhere you were going
somewhere about this why they would do
this
well what i'm saying is it's not even
privileged there's no reason to redact
it someone could ask me are you the
lawyer for pat
i say sure i'm not gonna tell you what
we talk about but it's not i can't say
you know what i mean these firms
brag if you go on his firm simpson
thatcher they'll brag we represent
google we represent yahoo we were part
of the alibaba ipo they brag about who
their clients are but in a deposition on
taxpayer dollars we can't get to know
what you're going to be fired up man i
got because what do you do
what do you do as a citizen
you're trying to live your life you're
trying to play by the rules they're
they're setting the rules you're trying
to play by the rules and then they come
and whenever they want they change them
and then you get no recourse the way you
feel right now is the way i felt on
christmas eve this time last year i felt
just like that and that's why i filed
the lawsuit so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]